when i give my clients advice i look at
them as if they're my mom my dad my
my cousin my sibling my best friend
because i know what it's like to be in
their shoes being
being an immigrant is scary
[Music]
anita kamriken thank you so much for
joining me how are you
thank you so much for having me i'm
doing well how are you i am i'm
fantastic as well
did i get the name right first of all
anita kamiki and yes that's the american
way of staying good
and where are you from i was born in
iraq um but i'm
um actually armenian okay
wow so uh you know we're talking right
now from
a from the from the the offices alcorn
offices right
correct alcorn immigration law we're
located in mountain view california
so uh you know so i i got to speak to
quite a few lawyers through this show
but this is
going to be a special episode because
i'm going to learn all about immigration
law
and i it's specifically immigration law
in the context also of silicon valley
which is a
hugely relevant especially nowadays and
i'd love to talk about how it impacts
how it's impacted during covid how it's
changed over you know
perhaps past the the last decade or so
and
and i'd love to hear also your story
about why you're working in immigration
law
and there's a lot of different places in
life especially in silicon valley
so how about we get started talk to me a
little bit about your journey and how
you found yourself working at
immigration law
sure so as i mentioned earlier i i'm an
immigrant myself i was born in iraq
and my family moved over to the united
states in 1995
my parents decided to make sure that my
my two older sisters and i could live an
american dream
where we would leave a war ridden
country and come to the united states
on the 20-year anniversary of us being
in the united states i
graduated from law schools to really
live that american dream
so growing up i've always known i wanted
to do something to help people and when
i was younger it was always oh maybe
i'll be a doctor
maybe i'll do this maybe i'll do that um
and it was about the seventh grade i was
12 years old i thought to myself
i see so many of my family members so
many of my
the people in my community kind of
struggle through the immigration field
of like
do we need a lawyer oh i became a
citizen i'm getting my green card all of
this and
i kind of told myself my parents
and i was super young so i really didn't
know my parents
my parents came to this unite the united
states
struggled um to get us here today
so that we can live our american dream
i'm going to make my parents proud
go to school educate myself as much as i
can so that i can help
people like my family when we first
moved to the united states so
um finished school obviously i went to
ucla for undergrad santa clara law for
law school
and joined the immigration field and
that's what i'm i'm passionate about i
absolutely love it
um i have experience practicing family
law as well
um so divorces and all of that and it's
it's i'm glad that i've done it i'm glad
i have it in my in my
um my pocket of experience and knowledge
um
but i love immigration so can you give
me a little bit of context as to
the immigration situation in the united
states i know that it's a very
a popular topic of debate especially in
politics
but i'd love to understand a little bit
better you know
what what is the immigration situation
in the united states the united states
is known as
a country that that hosts a lot of
immigrants from all over the world this
american dream
i'm originally from israel even though i
was specifically born in the us but
but a lot of my friends are immigrants
to the us so talk to me a little bit
about what's happening
so right now well for the past four
years
um it's been a it's been very very up
and down immigration
um everybody for the longest time
um has has built the concept of the
american dream we want to come to the
united states and
and join the melting pot um and that's
really transformed over time especially
now as
america becomes less and less immigrant
friendly unfortunately
um but there's still there's still hope
that's what i tell people every day
um especially now um there's still hope
there's it just requires some creativity
of kind of thinking outside of the box
of if we can't get you into the united
states with this type of visa or this
type
type of green card um let's think how
else we can
how else we can work with you to to to
get you into the united states
um every every
um presidential candidacy has has their
own
agendas in terms of immigration some are
better than others um
and being in the immigration field you
kind of have to learn to
to go with the go with the flow and
every four years they have to adapt
every four years sometimes eight years
um and
yeah you just have you have to adapt you
um have to learn to
sometimes um go go with the punches and
and
swerve around them um since um march
specifically and covid
um it's been especially difficult um in
my
my years of being an immigration
attorney there's never been such a
volatile time to be an immigration
attorney where
i feel like every single day we kind of
have to keep our ears peeled to see
is there something new going on is there
a new proclamation is there a new order
what can we um
what what is going on that we have to
let our clients know about so i feel
like i've
partially also turned into a journalist
where um
we we hear everything and then we kind
of try to
to put it in our own words and and send
it out a new
newsletter to our clients and people in
our network so for
so for those that are watching before we
dive deep into more of the work of an
immigration law
can you explain a little bit better why
why why is there a controversy
in in the democratic nation of the the
united states
a democracy and that that the american
dream is something that you know every
person in the world i think
learns about when they think of the
united states what has been
so controversial about immigration over
the past several decades
and and why is it even an issue um
i mean it's an issue because it in my
opinion it's a silly issue but it's
it's the it's the fear it's the
protection of
um american jobs really it's the
protection of our economy of people
coming to the united states whether it
be legally or illegally
and taking taking american jobs which
in every immigration attorney's eyes or
every immigrant size themselves
is not really is not a thing i'm trying
to stay as a political as i possibly can
during this
um of course but it um
it's just out of out of fear of of
protection of american jobs of the
american economy
um and i i believe that's what it really
stems from
so when with democrats in office there's
a different
agenda there's different a different
mind frame whereas when there's
conservative or public
republicans um in office there's there's
a different
different agenda in a different mind
frame um
and so that's the adaptability that
we're talking about and then so
what is the what is the privilege that
you have as the as an immigration law
um attorney do you is your primary job
helping people
fulfill their their goal of coming into
the us
legally absolutely so what our goal is
um and what i always tell people
um at alcorn immigration law what we
focus on focus on is
helping individuals come to the united
states to live their american dream
regardless of their geographic location
their place of birth what their passport
looks like
we help individuals employers
employees immigrate here legally of
course
so that they can come here live here
stay here work here
um and it's it's that's what we focus on
again we do both employment-based
immigration as well as family-based
immigration
um because they're two while it's
they're both under the immigration law
um umbrella they're vastly different um
types of immigration right so so
being in silicon valley what is the
difference between speaking to you that
you're based in mountain view
versus if i were to speak to an
immigration law attorney
let's say in michigan or in or in boston
so it really depends on the immigration
attorney and
the the abilities that they have to
work remotely right now everybody is
working remote
um but what we what we pride ourselves
on being in the silicon valley is that
we try to be as cutting edge as we can
we have to
we have to work with and and not
necessarily compete with but keep up
with the tech
companies um so since the very start um
or birth of alcorn immigration law we
have been fully remote um
we help people worldwide i've had
clients
literally next door to our office and i
have clients in brazil
germany um china all around the world um
which makes my job so fun because i get
to work with people
worldwide um and whether or not they're
local or not local makes absolutely no
difference to us
we we have adapted to a fully remote
um environment but still i'm assuming
that
the majority of your apprentice is
people that want to relocate to silicon
valley
i'm sorry yes so most of the time it's
it's we practice specifically inbound
immigration we do not do
out out immigration um so it's people
coming to the silicon valley
um most of the time it's the silicon
valley otherwise it's i'm moving to the
united states i'm going to
work for an employer um in michigan um
and we can help them
i'm going to come and join my my spouse
who lives in texas and we can help them
right is it really complicated is it is
it really complex
getting authorized getting authorization
to move to the us
it is it's complex in that there's al
always so many different moving parts
and there's so many different hoops that
you have to jump through
whenever i'm talking to to clients or
potential clients or anybody about
immigration i always tell them
what do you want to invest in or how do
you want to invest do you want to invest
your
your time your energy your your google
abilities to figure out
how to um file this application how to
get into the united states and do you
want to do it yourself or do you just
want to invest your money and just
kind of have an immigration professional
do the work for you so that you can put
your head down on a pillow and know
they've got it they're taking care of me
i don't have to worry about that
um so i mean call me bias but
if i were not an immigration attorney i
mean kind of like with my taxes
i don't file my own taxes i do not trust
myself i will convince myself that i'm
going to
do something where they're going to come
and say hey anita you're going to jail
because you didn't file
jerry right and this is a life decision
this is a dramatic
dramatic thing yes absolutely it's it's
vital
um to make sure that you're doing it
correctly so maybe you know and a high
level without
necessarily diving too deep if i'm
coming
if i'm coming now let's say i'm from i'm
from holland and i want to
come to silicon valley because i have
potential i potentially want to start a
startup
and relocate to palo alto or to michigan
which is also a great tech hub
what what are some of the biggest steps
or biggest hurdles
that i might have to go through until i
become a us citizen
so first um the first step obviously is
finding an
employer who will sponsor you to come
into the united states with either a
temporary
non-immigrant visa or with an immigrant
visa which is also known as a green card
so there are two separate kind of things
what does that mean a sponsor i've heard
this term quite a few times what does it
mean for a company to sponsor somebody
so in order for somebody to enter the
united states
whether it's through an employer
employer relationship or a family
relationship
you have to file an underlying petition
where somebody says
i'm a united states employer and i want
that person
in armenia to come and work for me
i'm going to sponsor their employment
here in the united states
so they're going to come and work for my
company and
only my company with this specific type
of visa
and there's so many different types of
visas um on the flip side
i can say i'm i'm in the united states
um and i want my
my spouse my fiance to join me in the
united
um outside of the united states join me
in the united states so that we can live
our life here i'm going to sponsor
them here to come into the united states
so it's that underlying petition that
underlying sponsorship
that will allow somebody to enter the
united states
so it's less of a financial it's more of
a it's not a financial sponsorship it's
more of a
i'm vouching that i am the reason i'm
the sole reason of why they want to come
here
right correct there's also a financial
sponsorship aspect
of it depending on the type of of status
that they're entering in on if it's
family based status then the
the individual that petitioner has to
pledge if this person enters the united
states
i'm going to take care of them
financially if they obtain
any kind of public benefits food stamps
welfare anything from the government
if they get that i will pay the us
government back because i'm their
financial sponsor
so financial sponsorship is different
than
like petitioning somebody to enter into
the united states
okay that makes and has this industry
evolved over the past i don't know
decade or two decades so
i'm always curious when i when i
approach new industries that i don't
know and
especially law which you know in my mind
i'm still thinking back
you know i'm imagining like a law school
and you know dusty shelves and people
are just like reading books and arguing
in court
has this industry involved immigration
law kind of not really um
immigration is pretty archaic um there
is the immigration and nationality act
that was um
founded it's the law that that fined
or founded immigration um that was it's
it was years ago that that was founded
so it's
kind of archaic the laws the rules in
there are
are bold um i think immigration needs
like
it needs a home makeover it needs a
renovation um but it's so hard
to do um immigration laws change
a lot immigration laws change often um
and like specifically with with more
recently um in terms of financial
sponsorship
um there's a new public charge rule that
was was kind of buffed up
just recently um back in it started in
october of 2019
really started in february of 2020 is
now off again and is going to
possibly be turned on again it's it's
the new idea of of self-sufficiency when
an immigrant is coming into the united
states
they need to declare hey i'm young um i
speak english i have a degree i'm gonna
come into the united states and i'm
going
i'm employable i can work i'm not going
to be a public charge
so they need to declare their
self-sufficiency as well so
while immigration is archaic does kind
of need reform
um if you speak to any immigration
attorney
at the same time they are they are
trying to
adapt to the times as well so it sounds
like a lot of the complexity here for
immigration
and i'm getting a better understanding
of this here is that a lot of it is is
ensuring that
you know is is looking at the economy
that's a primary factor it's it's
looking at
and and how much the government will
have to provide
for for citizens that may not be
self-sustaining and then i guess
your role as an immigration attorney
professional
is to is to bridge that gap and to be
able to help
whoever wants to fulfill that american
dream to meet
to to show that they're able to meet
those requirements
so that they can get the authorization
right yes
absolutely and that's that's what that's
where that's where our job kicks in
that's what our requirement is is as
immigration attorneys it's our job to
to be creative to make sure that we're
on top of all of all of the laws
ethically we are required to do that
we're requires
as an attorney there's so many ethical
obligations that we have but it's making
sure that we stay up to date with the
laws and making sure that
clients do qualify that um and
and doing what we can to kind of be
creative and nimble with
with everything as well to to get
whoever wants to come
into the united states into the united
states how long does this process take
because it must take
years right to get this done not
necessarily it all depends on the type
of visa
or the type of green card that you want
to enter in on
um so it can take anywhere from a couple
of months to like
two three years um all the way up to
like 20 years
so it all it all depends on the type of
visa who's petitioning for you and how
you're getting into the united states
unbelievable unbelievable and so i'd
love to hear a little bit about
about your personal journey with within
with the immigration law
what what part of it are you do you
really get excited about because
obviously
you started law not an immigration so
you went to law school you go
into family law and and then he
transitioned to immigration have you
always known you'll end up in
immigration or is this something that
you stumbled upon and you said oh wow
like i'm connected to this and this is
something i'm curious about
i've always known that i wanted to do
immigration when i first started
working in the immigration field i
worked at a practice where we were doing
both family immigration
family-based immigration as well as
family law i did more of the
family-based immigration at that point
but i would always beg hey can i have
please have an immigration project can i
do this can i do that and then i
fully transitioned over to immigration
and now i'm a partner at the firm that i
work at
and i absolutely love it um and i
wouldn't i wouldn't want to practice any
other
field of law because for me immigration
hits home
and i get to work with so many different
types of clients all around the world
and they are all such a pleasure to work
with because
they want to work with me because they
get something good from me they get a
visa they get a green card
um and it's it's fun and
super rewarding as hard as it may be
um to be an immigration attorney and
sometimes kind of feel like a the pinata
of lawyers
right it's so rewarding as a partner
do you still do like what are the
differences and responsibilities between
being a partner at the firm
being a paralegal i'm not really too
versed with how law firms work but just
to paint a picture of what your daily
life looks like
um it all depends on um it all depends
on the firm
and how they how they how they work how
they manage partners oftentimes
do kind of more of the the higher end
speaking to potential new clients
um doing more of the business management
aspect of it marketing
um but sometimes also do still get to do
um pull up their sleeves and actually
get get to work on some legal work or at
least
mentor to get some legal work done um
whereas paralegals they're
they're just they're they're the ones
there they make the magic happen people
underestimate paralegals and how
much they do so i am so grateful for all
of our brilliant paralegals
everywhere um they're fantastic
so i i know that i'm keeping you one
minute late and i know you had a hard
stop that you have to
for a minute but but i have to i have to
ask you the most important question and
i'd love to understand a little bit
better
about you through that three words that
you would use to describe yourself and
please elaborate a little bit on these
words and and why those
why are those specifically because i
know you've put a lot of thought into
them
thanks um so one word i would say is
passionate i am so passionate for what i
do
for the the law that i practice um and
the people that i help it's that passion
that keeps me
um going um growing up i used to always
hear people say
anita you have to find a job that or a
career that
you love so that you will never have to
work a day in your life it's going to be
fun for you to do um and i was like
that's not true there's there's no way
that
people will actually want to work but it
is so there's any young listeners out
there
who are still kind of trying to find
what their passion is in in their career
it is out there look for it do not give
up um
i'm empathetic i'm empathetic because i
treat every one of my family member
every one of my clients as if they're my
own family members when i give my
clients advice
i look at them as if they're my mom my
dad my my cousin my sibling
my best friend because i know what it's
like to be in their shoes
being being an immigrant is scary
it's scary to to be in those shoes of
kind of really not knowing
what is going to happen with with my
fate in this country where i've
i've worked so hard to get to so you
have to be empathetic you have to
understand
um why your clients are stressed out why
they're anxious why they're
why their application has to be filed
today you have to get that
um and i'm i'm hardworking um if i
wasn't hardworking i don't think i would
be here
today um and it's it's
it speaks for the approval rate that i
pride myself on having i
i try my best on every single one of my
cases and
um my my my passion
and my empathy all comes in into it as
as well so those are my three words i
love it i need to thank you so so much
this was this is wonderful i learned so
much
and and i definitely think and i
definitely hope things will will get
better and easier
especially for my grins i can definitely
justify how wonderful of an experience
it
has been for me to to have both my home
country israel but also
be in silicon valley and in the united
states in general and you know just
recently when
when there was the big announcement that
foreign students when it goes online
they'll have to relocate back to their
country i was looking at a lot of my
friends i was looking at my friends from
africa from the middle east from from
europe and
and i i was shocked and i and i saw all
of a sudden how
how things were falling apart without
their control and it was very difficult
so i definitely appreciate
your work very very much thank you for
the insights and
stay safe and stay healthy thank you
thank you for having me